Sieht schon mal sehr gut aus.
Die Grösse ist gar so nicht falsch.
Sicher? Heisst das,
da muss noch etwas drunter?
Sie bekommen
sicher noch Unterschichten, absolut.
Den Reisverschluss - Achtung -
bis auf die Höhe des Kletts!
Oh, ja. Wieso?
- Bis auf die Höhe Ihres Kletts.
So ist das Tenue richtig.
Aha. Es gibt keinen Grund,
aber es muss so sein.
Doch. So ist es einheitlich.
Wir achten
auf die Einheit des ganzen Zugs.
Jetzt fehlen noch Schuhe
und Abzeichen. Die holen wir jetzt.
Sollen möglichst alle gleich werden.
Ist das das Ziel?
Nein, es geht nicht darum,
etwas zu unterdrücken,
sondern die Gemeinschaft hervor-
zuheben: Wir sind so alle gleich.
(Ich habe viel aufzuholen.)
(Die Winter-RS läuft schon
seit dreieinhalb Wochen.)
Dann haben Sie die Stau-Binde,
das Tourniquet,
um Blut direkt zu stoppen.
Das ist auch Sackbefehl.
Das haben Sie rechts im Hosenbein.
Sackbefehl heisst:
alles, was ich dabeihaben muss?
Alles, was Sie immer auf Mann haben.
- Okay.
Heisst das auch bei Frauen auf Mann?
- Ja. So heisst es auch bei Frauen.
Dann haben wir hier das GT.
Das ist Ihre Grundtrageeinheit.
GT? Wie viele Abkürzungen
haben Sie eigentlich?
Ich habe Sie nicht gezählt,
aber es sind viele. Lilö, GT ...
Lilö: Lichterlöschen,
GT: Grundtrageeinheit ...
Der Tagesrucksack heisst Tarusa,
der Kampfrucksack heisst Karusa.
Den packen wir nachher.
- Noch mehr? Herrgott!
Sie sind in der Infanterie gelandet.
Die Infanterie -
das ist das Fussvolk.
Der Vollfick?
Oder wie nennt man das?
Das haben Sie treffend ausgedrückt.
Ich wollte es erleben,
wie es  d e r  Soldat erlebt,
der nicht die ganze Zeit fährt,
sondern der viel läuft,
der das Kameradschaftsgefühl hat.
Woher kommt die Lust bei Ihnen,
tief unten durch,
im Dreck robben zu wollen?
Ich war elf Jahre
Leistungssportlerin.
Sagt Ihnen Tanja Frieden etwas?
Sie fuhren Snowboardcross?
Crossrennen?
Genau. Ich konnte das in den letzten
zwei Jahren als Profi machen,
hatte aber leider
viele Verletzungen.
Dann brauchte ich etwas,
was mich ähnlich fasziniert
und ähnlich meine Energie nimmt,
mir aber auch Struktur gibt.
Dann ging ich ins Schweizer Militär,
und ich bin absolut am richtigen Ort
für mich und dafür,
was ich gesucht habe.
(Alle) Stabskompanie!
(Ob das auch für mich gilt,
finde ich jetzt heraus.)
(Bis jetzt
bin ich recht froh gewesen,
dass das Militär
an mir vorbeigegangen ist.)
Kompanie ruhn!
19-mal AR2,
23-mal ABC, acht Mötis,
zweimal Kurs Bern, dreimal Bettruhe.
Kompanie ruhn! Morgen.
- (Alle) Morgen!
Heute Verschiebung zu Fuss
ins Breitfeld,
anschliessend Sturmgewehr,
Übermittlungsdienst,
OBeSchüDiZ
und Grundverhalten der Truppe.
Ziel von heute: das Gelernte
von letzter Woche umzusetzen.
Zu zwei hinter Peretic treten,
Marsch!
Machen Sie vorwärts!
Dann die Packung auf Mann nehmen,
in zwei Kolonnen eingestanden!
Ausführen!
(Es geht von der Kaserne Herisau
auf den Übungsplatz Breitfeld.)
(50 Min. Marsch oder Lauf - mit
ca. 30 kg Gepäck auf dem Rücken.)
* Gewehrsalven *
(Und dann wird es feierlich.)
(Ich erhalte nämlich ein Stück
des staatlichen Gewaltmonopols.)
(Konkret: ein Sturmgewehr.)
(Zum Glück hat man mir gesagt,
was ich ungefähr tun muss.)
Treten Sie näher!
In der Schweizer Armee
haben alle eine persönliche Waffe,
die wir mit Verantwortungs-
bewusstsein übernehmen.
Ich übergebe Ihnen jetzt
die persönliche Waffe.
Ich übernehme die persönliche Waffe.
- Sehr gut.
Sie werden ausgebildet,
damit Sie die gezielt einsetzen
und verantwortungsbewusst
damit handeln können.
Melde mich ab.
- Ja.
Besten Dank.
- Bitte.
Die Herren: Rekrut Vetsch ist
komplett neu, wie Sie am ersten Tag.
Achten Sie auf sie!
Achtung, Castaneda!
Sie haben sich genau
vor Rekrut Vetsch gestellt.
Nein,
ich habe mich hinter ihn gestellt.
Mir nach, Marsch!
(Und schon bin ich
in der Grundausbildung.)
Sie führen die Gruppe
bis in ein Daher vor die Scheibe!
(Es gibt verschiedene Posten.)
(Das ist aber das Einzige,
was ich checke.)
Das Ziel der heutigen Lektion ist:
Jeder ADA
kann die Grundmanipulationen
fehlerfrei anwenden -
was Sie schon kennen und was für
Rekrut Vetsch neu ist. Wo ist sie?
Hier.
- Genau.
Kontaktstellung. Ausführen!
(Als Ex-Jungschützin
erschreckt mich das Gewehr nicht.)
(Aber so im Kämpfer ist es anderes.)
Das sind keine ...
Mit denen kannst du nicht schiessen?
Das sind keine richtigen Patronen.
- Dummie-Patronen für uns.
Das Magazin nehmen Sie so raus,
dass Sie im Gefecht so schnell
wie möglich agieren können.
Waffe laden!
Verstanden?
- (Alle) Verstanden.
Ausführen!
Sie haben jetzt Pause.
Verstanden.
- Gut, ausführen!
(Zeit für die Zwipf,
die Zwischenverpflegung.)
Und Sie, haben Sie Angst
vor den nächsten drei Tagen?
Ehrlich gesagt
habe ich mehr Angst um euch,
falls ich mal
scharfe Munition bekomme.
Wir passen schon auf.
- Da habe ich Angst um euch.
Es ist ja schon speziell:
Eigentlich
musst du dir immer vorstellen,
wenn du dein Gewehr hältst,
dass du wirklich mal
auf jemanden schiessen musst.
Man muss sich
keine falschen Vorstellungen machen.
Das Militär ist für den Krieg da.
So ist es halt.
Das stört dich nicht?
Solange ich
auf niemanden schiessen muss nicht.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wir in den Krieg ziehen
oder das Land verteidigen müssen,
ist ziemlich klein.
Prinzip Hoffnung,
dass es nie so weit kommt? - Ja.
Wie ist es für euch, dass
euer Wachtmeister eine Frau ist?
Ganz normal.
- Nein, das ist nicht normal!
Es sind schon wenige Frauen,
aber ob Mann oder Frau spielt
für mich persönlich keine Rolle.
(In der Schweizer Armee
ist nicht einmal 1 % Frauen.)
(Das VBS hätte gerne mehr.)
Lass mal die Arme draussen!
Lernt man hier was,
ausser zu gehorchen?
Meiner Meinung nach
ist es ein Ziehen an einem Strang.
Zusammenhalten.
Man wird halt
mit Leuten zusammengeworfen,
in irgendeinem Hinterland.
- So mit denen da?
Ja. Mit Leuten,
die man noch nie gesehen hat.
Alle sind in derselben Situation
und müssen irgendwie durchbeissen.
Mal ist es lustig, mal das
Schlimmste, was ich je gemacht habe.
Es ist richtig anstrengend.
Es sind 16-Std.-Tage.
Du stehst um 5 Uhr früh auf,
bist den ganzen Tag auf den Beinen,
wirst den ganzen Tag rumgescheucht:
da laufen, dies, Posten.
Wenn man nach Hause kommt
noch Gewehr und Schuhe putzen etc.
So streng?
- Ja ... Doch.
Also ...
Ist Ihnen kalt?
- Nein, ist gut.
Gut, tipptopp.
So. Pause vorbei.
Legen Sie sich auf die Matte!
Legen Sie sich hin!
(Leute durchsuchen, notfalls
gefesselt: der nächste Posten.)
Bewegen Sie Ihren linken Arm
auf den Rücken! Ausführen!
Der Arm kommt.
Ich nehme ihn gleich dazu.
So. Und jetzt ist Rekrut Brioschi
gefesselt und fest.
Achtung.
Sie knien am Boden,
nicht auf Rekrut Vetsch.
Jawohl.
Die Bewegungen sind gut,
aber es muss schneller gehen.
Sie haben noch
den Daumen eingeklemmt.
Auch auf der Decke
wird es kalt und nass.
Machen Sie die Durchsuchung schnell.
(Wobei:
Ungemütlich ist eigentlich nur
der Geruch
der feuchten Armeewolldecke.)
Rekrut Vetsch,
Sie dürfen sich erheben.
Wie hängst du das Gewehr um?
- Einfach irgendwie hinten.
Einmal noch über den Kopf.
(Rekrut Hedinger hilft mir.
Überhaupt schauen alle zueinander.)
(Aus Kameradschaft
oder Angst vor Sanktionen?)
(Das ist mir noch nicht klar.)
Wie viel Platz ist noch?
Der Churer fragt, ob
seine acht Leute mitkommen können.
(Es ist kalt, und nach einem Tag
auf dem Feld sind alle müde.)
Du kannst.
- Alle mir nach, Marsch!
Bis später.
(Feierabend ist aber noch nicht.)
(Wir müssen noch das Gewehr putzen.)
(Neben mir: Rekrut Gagica.)
2 Min. ab jetzt!
Ausführen!
(Ein Drittel aller Rekruten
hat einen Migrationshintergrund.)
(Azem Gagica ist Secondo
aus Kroatien, erzählt er mir.)
Drei, zwei, eins, gut!
Ist die Schweizer Armee
anders als die kroatische?
Kennt dein Vater, was du erzählst?
Oder war das bei ihm völlig anders?
Es war sicher anders.
Sie hatten ...
Da war halt Kriegsfall.
Wir haben es "gemütlicher".
Bei uns ist kein Krieg.
Wir lernen alles
und die mussten alles ...
Aber das wäre doch ein Grund für
einen Vater, seinem Sohn zu sagen:
"Geh nie in die Armee!"
Und du willst trotzdem in die Armee?
Ja.
- Wieso?
Ich fühle mich hier gut aufgehoben.
Wir sind halt so aufgewachsen.
- Damit, dass Militär was Gutes ist?
Ja. Dass man viel lernen kann.
Im Kriegsfall - irgendwer muss
die Leute um sich rum schützen.
Wenn alle sagen würden:
"Ich mache es nicht." Dann, ja ...
(Was mir Rekrut Gagica nicht sagt:
Er hat ständig Rückenschmerzen.)
(Mit den Märschen
und v.a. dem Tragen hat er Mühe.)
Haben Sie solche Schmerzen?
- Ja.
Geben Sie ab!
- Ich bin zu stolz.
Geben Sie es Hedinger, wenn Sie
zu stolz sind, es mir zu geben!
Nein, nein. Zu stolz allgemein,
es irgendwem zu geben.
Morgen gehen Sie
in die Physiotherapie, verdammt!
Wo muss ich hin?
Kontrolle bei Wachtmeister Schmid.
(Dann erfahre ich, dass ich genau
am richtigen Tag eingerückt bin:
Immer am Mittwoch
ist in der Kaserne Herisau Ausgang.)
(Ich stelle fest:
Das Militär bleibt auch
in der raren Freizeit unter sich.)
Zum Wohl. Rekrut Vetsch.
Ich bin nur drei Tage im Militär.
- Besser für Sie.
Sonst sind Sie nachher so - wie wir.
Wir sind schon nach vier Wochen so.
Gaga?
- Ja.
Warum?
- Zu viel Stress im Militär.
Nein. Es ist eine geile Erfahrung.
Aber soll ich Ihnen etwas sagen?
Sie würden vom Wachtmeister
ein Tenue NEF bekommen.
Oh, wieso?
- Ihr Schuhband ist offen.
(Tenu NEF - nicht erfüllt.
Der Drill gilt auch im Ausgang.)
Danke für so viel
kollegiale Unterstützung.
Das muss man.
Sonst ist das nicht erfüllt.
(Dann, wenn im zivilen Leben
der Ausgang anfängt,
hört er im Militär auf: um 23 Uhr.)
(Tagwache: 5.30 Uhr.)
(Schon wieder 1'000 Dinge,
an die man denken muss.)
(Rekrut Hauri hilft.)
Die Packung hast du fertig?
- Ja ...
Schlafsack und Helm noch.
Not really.
Und dass die Uniform immer
im zweiten Knopf zugemacht wird,
hat man dir gesagt?
Da, der zweite Knopf. - Nein.
Mütze oder Beret?
O Sch... Wo habe ich die? Nein!
Wir dürfen erst nach dem Frühstück
betten, damit es auslüftet. - Aha.
Das muss ich mitnehmen? - Nein. Zum
Frühstücken brauchst du gar nichts.
Gut, vorwärtsmachen!
5 Min. vor der Zeit
ist des Infanteristen Pünktlichkeit.
(Gut, dass wir uns beeilt haben -
denn jetzt heisst es wieder:
warten.)
Guten Appetit.
- (Alle) Guten Appetit.
(Für das Frühstück
müssen 10 Min. reichen.)
(Nachher heisst es: fertig packen.)
(Für die nächste Nacht
ist ein Biwak draussen angesagt.)
Die Gamelle ausgelegt
in 2 1/2 Min. ab jetzt!
(Selbstverständlich wird
kontrolliert, ob wir alles haben.)
Und zwar
nach dem Vorbild Ihrer Kameraden.
Nein! Nein, also nein.
Ein bisschen subversiv muss es sein.
(Wenigstens mein Gamellen-Napf
soll schräg sein dürfen.)
Sie sehen,
da würde mein Problem beginnen.
Freude an Dingen,
die etwas aus der Reihe tanzen.
Daran habe ich auch Freude.
Aber dafür ist wenig Platz.
* Eintönige Marschklänge *
Gut. Erster Schritt:
alle das Tourniquet aufmachen!
Ausführen!
(Heute lernen wir,
eine Blutung zu stoppen.)
(Für den bitteren Ernstfall.)
Zweiter Schritt:
um das Bein wickeln!
(Mit dem sog. Tourniquet
müssen wir das Bein
so fest wie möglich abbinden.)
Ziehen Sie das Tourniquet an,
sodass Sie es spüren!
Stellst du dir jetzt vor,
dass du mit angeschossenem Bein
im Feld liegst?
Wenn ich Glück habe.
Nein, ich hoffe es nicht.
Wie lange geht es, bis das abstirbt?
Man sollte es nicht länger
als 40 Sek. so lassen.
Also besser jetzt aufstehen.
Versuchen Sie es! Wenn Sie
auf Ihrem Bein noch stehen können,
haben Sie etwas falsch gemacht.
Ah! Scheisse.
Ah!
- Spüren Sie das Bein noch?
So halb. Nein.
Ziehen Sie es wieder aus!
Alle wieder lösen! Sofort,
damit Sie sich nicht verletzen.
(Dauerthema auf dem Übungsplatz:
der Schlafmangel.)
(Die Armee
schreibt 6 Std. Nachtruhe vor.)
(Rekrut Hedingers Statistik
sagt anderes.)
Ich habe einen Fitnesstracker,
der zeigt, wie viel ich schlafe.
Die ganze Woche sieht es mau aus.
- Zeig mal!
Da sind 4 1/2 Std. -
6 Std., wenn es gut läuft.
5 Std., 5 Std. und 15 Min.
Stresst dich das am meisten
im Militär?
Ich weiss nicht. Auch.
Du musst komplett den Kopf aus-
schalten, nicht selbst nachdenken.
Alles wird dir gesagt.
Aber dann ist halt immer Stress.
Das Krasseste ist: Du weisst nicht,
ob du weitermachen musst.
Du kannst nicht Nein sagen? - Doch,
aber sie können dich zwingen.
Aber dagegen werde ich
Himmel und Hölle in Bewegung setzen.
Wo ist Ihr GT?
- Ich habe das nicht.
Okay, gut.
Da ist viel Schmutz drin.
- O Gott.
Ist Schmutz. Dreck. Dreck ist hier.
- Ah.
Schauen Sie: die Waffe nach oben,
damit nicht immer Schmutz drin ist!
(Für die Tessiner Kameraden
ist die RS auch ein Sprachkurs.)
Schauen Sie, dass Sie
auf einer geraden Linie sitzen!
Immer noch keine gerade Linie.
Schützen, ich gebe
das Schiessprogramm bekannt.
Einmal drei Schuss. Waffe laden!
Sehr gut. Und jetzt Kontrollblick,
ob ein Patrone drin ist.
(Zuletzt habe ich
vor 20 Jahren geschossen.)
Bereit, Feuer!
* Schüsse *
(Hier im Militär
ist es ein ganz anderes Gefühl.)
Feuer halt!
Waffe ist gesichert
und hinterhängen!
(Viel Zeit zum Nachdenken
ist nicht.)
Einmal da, einmal da, einmal da.
Die Position sollte noch stabiler
sitzen. Gut. Sie dürfen abkleben.
(Gar nicht so schlecht.)
Wie haben Sie
das Schiessen als solches erlebt?
Für mich ist Schiessen
recht faszinierend.
Mir gibt manchmal zu denken,
dass man keine Sekunde überlegt,
was man in der Hand hält.
Man spricht vom Gegner,
schiesst auf eine Scheibe
und vergisst es komplett.
Das beschäftigt natürlich.
Mich auch, als ich daran dachte,
Militärdienst zu leisten.
Bis ich an dem Punkt bin,
an dem mir effektiv bewusst ist:
"Jetzt könnte wirklich
jemand vor mir stehen",
das ist ein relativ langer Weg.
Aber sind Sie so weit?
Also wenn es ernst gelten würde,
könnten Sie das?
Das weiss ich erst,
wenn es so weit ist.
(Alle müssen es üben,
aber viele verdrängen lieber,
worum es eigentlich geht.)
(Jetzt kommt das Nacht-Biwak
immer näher.)
Es ist wirklich ein Kampf
um jeden verdammten Millimeter.
Und aktuell verliere ich ihn.
Puh!
* Sie lacht. *
Ich schwör's:
Er ist gleich schwer wie ich.
Nummerieren!
- Verstanden, nummerieren! Zwo!
Vier!
- Sechs. - Acht. - Zehn.
Einbooten!
(Wir müssen nicht zu Fuss gehen.
Das steht schon mal fest.)
Wo fahren wir jetzt hin?
- Das wissen wir selbst nicht genau.
In den Wald wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil es regnet.
Sonst wären wir zu Fuss gegangen,
nehme ich mal an.
Entweder fahren wir in den Wald
zum Biwakieren
oder in eine Häuserkampfanlage,
wo es überdacht ist,
wo es uns nicht vollregnet.
Es ist zwar dementsprechend kalt,
aber Hauptsache trocken.
Was hoffst du?
- Dass es bald vorbei ist.
(Nach einem langen Tag unterwegs
in der Kälte mit unbestimmtem Ziel.)
(Ich bin sicher nicht die Einzige,
die sich fragt,
warum man all das
eigentlich mitmacht.)
Wo sind wir?
* Klappern, Knarzen *
Das Berufsmilitär
hat sich entschieden,
dass es zu nass und zu dreckig ist,
um im Wald zu schlafen.
Wir warten mal auf den Leutnant.
Keine Ahnung. Weiss auch nicht mehr.
Warten Sie mal hier!
* Schüsse *
Zug 1, hier lang!
Stabskompanie.
Gut. Folgen Sie!
(Drinnen wird es noch kälter.
Und dunkler.)
Rekrut Vetsch.
- Jawohl.
Hier rein.
- Separee? Oh, la, la.
Es gibt kein Licht.
Einfach mal Packung deponieren
und neben die Packung stellen!
Jetzt stehen wir hier einfach.
Irgendwo in einem Häuserkampfhaus,
in einem dunklen Loch.
Falls Sie das Gefühl haben,
es gäbe ja Licht: nein.
Das ist unsere Produzentin, die
reinleuchtet, damit man etwas sieht.
Wir nehmen schnell das Licht weg.
So sieht es aus.
* Schüsse *
(Ohne Stirn- und Taschenlampe
geht hier drin gar nichts.)
(Die Vorgesetzten
organisieren sich.)
(Und die Rekruten
warten auf weitere Befehle.)
Wie schätzen Sie es ein?
Wie wird es heute Nacht?
Es wäre draussen angenehmer,
wenn der Niederschlag nicht wäre.
Das glaube ich auch.
- Es strahlt schon Kälte ab.
Was ich empfehle -
wir haben da eine Zelteinheit -,
dass wir die ausrollen und unter-
legen als zusätzliche Isolation.
Das ist super. Das machen wir.
Was ist eigentlich das Ziel?
Was lernen wir in dieser Nacht?
Die Rekruten
lernen die eigenen Grenzen kennen.
Was es bedeutet,
wenn man wirklich friert
und schlecht geschlafen hat, wie
man dann am nächsten Tag drauf ist.
Aber man weiss ja mittlerweile,
dass Leute mit Schlafmangel
viel schlechtere Leistungen bringen.
Ist das nicht kontraproduktiv?
Was bringt der Schlafentzug?
- Das ist eine gute Frage.
Darauf habe ich keine Antwort,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Wir üben für das Gefecht.
Im Gefecht kann es sein, dass wir
drei Tage am Stück nicht schlafen.
(Seine Grenzen
soll man in der RS kennenlernen.)
(Die meisten in meiner Truppe
wissen schon,
was damit gemeint ist.)
Als wir hierher verschoben wurden,
gab es wirklich einen Moment,
da hatte ich die Schnauze voll.
Da musste ich wirklich sagen,
jetzt würde ich nach Hause gehen.
Das gibt es jeden Tag.
Aber es legt sich auch wieder.
Wenn ich dich jetzt frage ...
Willst du es wirklich durchziehen
oder denkst du darüber nach,
abzubrechen?
Darüber denke ich jeden Tag nach.
Aber letztendlich bin zu stolz, um
zu gehen, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Es wäre mir peinlich,
nach Hause zu gehen.
Ganz ehrlich.
Das lässt mein Stolz nicht zu.
Ich kann auch nicht mein Leben lang
vor Sachen davonlaufen,
nur weil sie anstrengend sind.
Das ist nicht der Sinn der Sache.
Ja, dito!
Einer hat mir gesagt, er nehme
immer die Schuhe in den Schlafsack,
damit die Schuhe
am Morgen nicht kalt sind.
Das machen wir auch.
- Gut.
Wir nehmen noch etwas anderes in den
Schlafsack, und zwar unser Gewehr.
Nein.
Doch, das machen wir.
Das ist Tradition.
Und wenn man die erste Nacht mit
dem Gewehr im Biwak verbracht hat,
dann darf man ihm einen Namen geben.
- Meine Fresse.
Also ich habe es gemacht,
auch zum Schutz des Gewehrs.
Wie heisst es?
- Elvis.
Ich schiesse mit ihm, und seither
habe ich eine Hassliebe zu ihm.
Okay.
(Dann spiele ich
das Spiel halt mit.)
(So kann es mir
wenigstens keiner klauen.)
Das ist der Moment
für die Wärmepads.
(Es ist unter null hier drin.)
Bis jetzt geht es unheimlich gut
mit der Wärme.
Darf ich sagen, dass Sie erst
seit 1 Min. im Schlafsack liegen?
Sie dürfen. Aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass es schlimmer wird.
* Gewehrsalven *
Also, gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht, Rekrut Vetsch.
* Gewehrsalven *
(Irgendwann
hat der Schiesslärm aufgehört.)
(Und schnell wird es wieder Tag.)
Aufstehen!
Hier sind schon alle wach.
Morgen miteinander.
- (Männer) Morgen.
Aufstehen!
Mann, ist das kalt hier draussen.
Ja,
jetzt kommt der unangenehmste Teil:
das Aufstehen.
Aber ging es mit der Wärme?
Das fand ich
die grosse Überraschung:
Ich habe überhaupt nicht gefroren.
Haben Sie einen Namen gefunden?
Mein Gewehr heisst Karl-Heinz.
Karl-Heinz?
- Ja, ich glaube: Karl-Heinz.
(Lachend) Alles klar.
- Ja, oder?
(Es ist ein wunderschöner Morgen.)
(Aber nach einer Nacht
auf dem Betonboden
weiss man das nicht so zu schätzen.)
Es gibt warmen Porridge
und Brot und Konfi. En Guete.
* Die Männer rufen durcheinander. *
Heute bin ich sehr schnell genervt.
Also gehen Sie mir
nicht auf die Eier!
Ich versuche es.
(Es sind nicht alle in Bestform.
Und dennoch:
Trotz der ungemütlichen Nacht ist
die Stimmung erstaunlich munter.)
(Das Abenteuer
schweisst die Gruppe zusammen.)
(So schnell geht es
und schon habe ich das Gefühl,
ich gehöre ein wenig dazu.)
Schmid!
- Hier.
Schnauze!
(Überschlagende Stimme) He, Ruhe!
- Es ist Ruhe!
(Abmarsch. Zum Übungsplatz.
Wie jeden Tag.)
Rechts drehen! Marsch!
Halt!
Links drehen! Marsch!
Auf links, rechts, links.
Links, links, links!
(Einfach mitlaufen und parieren.
Warum auch nicht?)
(Irgendwann
kommt man in einen Modus,
in dem man sich
nicht mehr zu viele Fragen stellt.)
Links, links, links,
links, rechts, links.
Einmal Richtung links!
En Guete.
- Gleichfalls.
(Das letzte Mittagessen
mit Kamerad Hedinger,
der eigentlich Pascal heisst
und Konstrukteur ist.)
Aber jetzt ist Freitag.
- Ja.
Zum Glück. Morgen nach Hause.
Dann gehe ich zuerst mal schlafen.
Was geniesst man am meisten
am Wochenende?
Bei mir ist es das Alleinsein.
Im Militär
hast du keine Sekunde für dich.
Ich bin zwar schon ein Geselliger.
Aber irgendwann reicht es mir.
Dann gehe ich gern nach Hause
und bin mal für mich,
habe mal meine Ruhe.
Ja.
(Für die Vorfreude aufs Wochenende
haben sie ein Ritual.)
Wichtig ist ...
- (Alle) ... dass Freitag ist.
- ... dass Freitag ist.
Besser wär ...
- ... wenn Samstag wär.
Scheisse ist ...
- ... wenn Sonntag ist.
Nein, nein, nein.
- Morgen gehen wir heim.
Ja, ja, ja.
- Am Sonntag sind wir da.
* Unverständlicher Befehl *
Für Sie Häsibe,
bis weitere Befehle folgen.
Dann: Rekrut Vetsch,
wir kommen langsam an ein Ende.
Jawohl.
Wie hat es Ihnen gefallen?
- Gefallen ist ein grosses Wort.
Viele sagen, es sei eine Kuschel-RS.
Nur früher sei es hart gewesen.
Auch wenn ich
nicht so viel gesehen habe:
Das stimmt so nicht.
Das höre ich gern.
Nicht, dass es
wahnsinnig streng war für Sie.
Aber das ist natürlich unser Alltag.
Wenn ich aufstehe, denke ich auch:
"Gott, schon wieder 5 Uhr."
Sie sind auch nicht mehr lange da,
habe ich gehört?
Ich bin noch zwei Wochen
Zugführer-Stv,
bevor ich an die Offiziersschule
in Liestal gehe.
Was wird dann aus Ihnen?
- Ein Leutnant.
Ist jetzt wohl der Moment
für das Duzis?
Das wollte ich gerade anbieten.
Ich bin Caro.
Ich bin Mona. Freut mich sehr.
- Freut mich.
(Überschlagende Stimme)
Detachement daher!
Es ist Zeit, dass wir uns von Mona,
Rekrut Vetsch, verabschieden.
Ich finde,
sie hat das sehr gut gemacht,
deshalb widmen wir ihr einen
Militärapplaus. Drei, zwei, eins!
Sehr schön, merci, dass du
bei uns warst. - Danke vielmals.
(Ich gehe, sie müssen
noch 14 Wochen hierbleiben.)
Melde mich ab, danke schön.
(Das Durchbeissen,
die Grenzerfahrung,
könnten mir an der RS
sogar gefallen.)
(Aber all die Vorschriften,
deren Sinn ich nicht sehe,
lasse ich noch so gerne zurück.)
(Ich gehe mit viel Respekt
vor jedem, der die RS durchhält,
ohne seinen Humor zu verlieren.)